voilà une information qui fait froid
dans le dos à strasbourg plusieurs
plaintes ont été déposées à l'encontre
de libraires travaillant pour des livres
ou antisémitisme
c'est la semaine dernière que deux
restaurateurs spécialisé dans la cuisine
israélienne se sont vus explicitement
refusé la livraison de leur commande à
leurs clients par un ou plusieurs
individus des libraires qui ont annulé
livraison et indiqué aux restaurateurs
via l'application
je ne livre pas aux juifs même scène
chez un restaurateur de la ville
spécialisée dans le cacher qui a lui
aussi déposé plainte
alerté de ces incidents l'application
des niveaux a réagi nous prenons cet
incident très au sérieux et avons
immédiatement décidé de mener notre
propre enquête interne pour tirer au
clair ces circonstances de son côté le
parquet de strasbourg a précisé
l'enquêté est en cours pour identifier
le mis-en-cause des actes qui inquiètent
toujours un peu plus quant à la montée
du racisme et de l'antisémitisme en
france
une histoire complètement folle un combo
raconte c'est vrai que c'est fou oui
tiffany oui alors ils disent sur des
lits verrou qui vont pénaliser justement
à les livreurs ça constitue un délit
pénal
mais je me pose la question je dis pas
qu'ils sont en cause mais comment est-ce
qu'il n'arrive pas à remettre la main
sur les mis en cause moi quand je fais
des livres ou quand je livre j'ai le nom
du livreur est oui et on me demande
qu'avez vous pensé de la livraison de
untel ou untel comment délit verrou
n'arrive pas à remonter la trace de
leurs livreurs alors on a avec elle est
semblable
justement m raphaël nice en est on à un
des restaurateurs qui est avec nous ça
va il on a les deux d'ailleurs à
bactéries rouge et et david merci parle
d'être là cette affaire a eu lieu ce
week-end merci d'être là merci d'être
avec nous parce que c'est important de
témoigner alors juste david vous êtes le
restaurateur que vous avez souhaité
rester cacher j'ai l'impression pour moi
david garder l'anonymat
vous avez peur des représailles vous
êtes voilà non je pense pas que
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce
qui s'est passé on va demander ou à
mettre nisand de nous en parler ou avoue
david qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement comme vous voulez en fait
jeudi soir il y à un niveau des libéraux
qui s'est présentée à la
restaurant et d'un avant que je lui
demande le numéro de commande
il m'a dit c'est quoi comme spécialité
ou à deux restaurants moi naturellement
je lui lis spécialité israélienne
d'accord il est bas à ce moment là il
m'a regardé et m'a dit ok alors joli
livre pas il a pris la tablette qu'il a
il a dit j'annule la commande à ce
moment là je lui ai dit mais pourquoi tu
annules 10e je lis pas le cacher je n'y
vais pas pour les juifs il est parti
vous l'avez alors alors vous avez
signalé
voilà moi à ce moment là j'ai dit moi ça
m'est jamais arrivé donc j'ai été sous
le choc
bien sûr donc j'ai un peu j'ai appelé un
peu les autres restaurants de strasbourg
pour les primes bien quoi qu'il y avait
une personne qui s'était présentée et là
j'ai un autre restaurateur qui m'a dit
oh purée il est passé il ya cinq minutes
chesnot et il m'a fait le même coup sauf
que je lui ai dit il m'a demandé si un
restaurant casher
est ce que tu sais peut-être qu'un des
vidéos puisque c'est peut-être quelqu'un
qui fait ça tous les restaurants casher
et tous les restaurants de spécialités
israélienne et qui se fait pas c'est
peut-être pour un livreur de des livres
ou et qui fait son truc voilà pour faire
passer un mauvais message
non parce que nous en fait on a des
tablettes d'accord dont le ilya dall
igna la livraison qui s'affiche donc
fait la commande dès que le livreur
vient récupérer ça clignote donc le
livre vient il nous dit le numéro de
commande d'ailleurs ensuite on lui remet
le paquet et lui valurent est alors
mettre les matrones disant vous avez
porté plainte auprès de délivrer ou non
pas auprès des livres ou parce qu'ils
sont totalement injoignable
donc les restaurateurs ont déposé
plainte vendredi matin et donc le
consistoire thierry rose qui à mes côtés
le porte parole du consistoire ma forme
est dépeinte des restaurateurs et m'a
demandé de déposer plainte pour le
quand ces histoires que j'ai déposée pas
pour une autre association également le
bnvca le bureau de vigilance contre
l'antisémitisme
je me suis joint donc à la plainte des
restaurateurs ou non des associations et
j'ai déposé plainte également contre des
livres ou parce qu'une analyse juridique
faisait apparaître que le livreur et
bien il était un commis de délits vers
où il travaille pour des libéraux donc
il fallait ne serait ce que pour avoir
une assistance un peu positif de des
livres ou dans le cadre de l'anc est
déposé plainte également contre des
livres ou thierry le porte parole du
consistoire israélite du bas-rhin
ça vous a sauté cette cette affaire
parce qu on a du mal à y croire c'est
vrai qu'on se dit c'est complètement fou
mais d'abord on ya toujours la
sidération
et puis ensuite il faut évaluer
l'ampleur de l'événement qui ne faut
jamais minimiser
ça commence toujours par des insultes ça
commence par des verbes par des écrits
comme céline comme horace et on sait
comment ça se termine
et ça libère ça fait sauter les verrous
tout ça même si c'est l'effet de la rue
des faits quotidiens ça fait sauter des
verrous et certains se sentent pousser
des ailes et c'est ça qui est dangereux
c'est ça qu'il faut arrêter et je vous
remercie de dénoncer ça l'est dans votre
émission qui rentrent dit ouah je crois
que c'est ce message qu'il faut faire
passer que ce n'est pas banal
ce n'est pas juste une insulte et c'est
vrai qu'on parle souvent de racisme
d'antisémitisme
dans cette émission les chéris moi j'ai
qu'un truc à vous dire en ce moment on
vit une période vraiment incroyable
combien de fois l'année dernière on
croyait tous ces lettres la fin du monde
c'est vrai on s'est dit on vit dans une
période de crise sanitaire incroyable on
vit comme une guerre aujourd'hui je vous
le dis ce qu'ont vécu des années ceux
qui ont vécu la guerre
on est dans une guerre on va alors c'est
vrai qu'on est là pour vous divertir
tous les soirs mais aussi je vous dis il
faut qu'on soit vraiment tous unis en ce
moment c'est vraiment il faut qu'il y
ait une unité non pas nationale mais
mondiale en ce moment parce qu'on est
tous face à ce même problème et on
sépare voilà il y en a eu un professeur
et un instant qui nous parlait peut-être
encore de mutation que c'était une
course contre la montre
on est dans un mauvais film dans un film
n'aurait rien voilà d'un film de science
fiction et on se dit à un moment on va
se réveiller peut-être qu'on va dire
c'était qu'un film mais aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que le ce genre de
comportement ça c'est inadmissible
et ce sont les comportements est ici
ce soit les pour leurs emportements
raciste que ce soit les comportements
voilà sur homophobes
ça c'est vraiment des choses qu'on
condamne dans notre émission et je vous
le dis en ce moment on n'a besoin que
d'une chose et c'est ce qu'on essaie
vraiment le message qu'on essaie de
faire passer sinon touche pas à mon
poste
on a vraiment des besoins tous d'être
tous ensemble tous unis contre eux
vraiment je vous dis ce fléau qu'on est
en train de vivre en ce moment et ça on
en a pas besoin
voilà je vous le dis on n'en a pas
besoin et c'est pour ça que je le dis
tous les soirs la télé c'est que de la
télé quand je vois des guéguerres de
télé les choses comme ça en ce moment
c'est vraiment pas le moment je pense
vraiment voilà c'est vrai voilà quand on
doit il ya des choses beaucoup plus
importantes
et aujourd'hui on essaie de vous
informer et de vous divertir dans cette
émission et ça c'est un sujet qui nous
tenait à coeur parce que c'est
inadmissible aujourd'hui de vivre ça on
espère enfin voilà qui aura des
sanctions de la part de délits verrous
par rapport à ce livreur et on espère
que ça se reproduira plus parce que je
pense qu'ils avaient été extrêmement
choqué et je voudrais vous remercier de
nous avoir dit un petit mot ce soir sur
cette affaire merci merci à vous merci
mais non merci la télé moi et merci à
vous merci beaucoup
alors je rate il vous dira j rature mais
j'entends votre message de paix c'est
très très important il faut pas a malgré
tout aux banalités le fait qu'ils aient
un antisémitisme amour ans et que c'est
aujourd'hui le pays le plus touché en
france en la france était le pays le
plus touché en europe et je vous assure
on a parlé il ya quelques jours de la
prime benayoun rappelez vous ne serez
était aussi une injure y est pour ses
origines il ya les profanations
régulière de tombes juives en choeur il
ya des croix gammées avaient le visage
de simone veil est déguisé je suis allé
sur le lycée de munster de dagne
ariègeois des choses oui là mais j'ai
suivi sur les muqueuses de l'intérieur
je vois des gens qui parlent que dd je
vois maintenant des gens sur les
relations qu'ils sont voilà qui peuvent
avoir des hurons racistes islamophobes
ou antisémite
voilà et ça passe crème aujourd'hui bas
ça passe voilà on peut on peut avoir des
propos racistes antisémites islamophobes
sur les plateaux de télé ça passe crème
et ça ça sent mais je suis quand même
allé selon un site du ministère de
l'intérieur pour voir les actes
proprement dit est effectivement entre
2018 et 2019 il ya une 687 actes
antisémites une augmentation de 27% 1052
actes antichrétiens qui stagne et cent
cinquante à cent cinquante quatre actes
anti musulmans qui sont aussi en nette
augmentation
donc c'est vraiment
pas du tout même analyse et c'est un
show de cagayan moon et du racisme et
les cherry s'est vraiment pas le moment
moi je pense à tous à cette dette voilà
tout les lieux toutes les personnes de
confession juive qui nous regardent
je pense à toutes les contre les
personnes de confession musulmane qui
est moi je vois sur les réseaux ce qui
se passe entre les différentes
communautés entre et sur la communauté
de touche pas à mon poste il y en a
plein qui appelle vraiment à la paix qui
sont voilà qu'ils sont tous ensemble et
voilà et c'est vrai que même je vous dis
ou pinceau de religion ici et c'est vrai
que nous on n'y touche pas voilà dans
cette émission parce que ça nous fait
pas marrer voilà où je le dis à chaque
fois là ça nous fait pas marrer de 2,2
d'essayer de stigmatiser telle ou telle
religion ce qu'on veut nous pour nous
c'est qu'on soit tous ensemble et pour
nous il n'y a pas à diane tell religion
qui est mieux qu'une autre il ya juste
des coups ou des paccots oui mais il
faut que ses livres soient punis de
manière exemplaire si quand vous les
choix publics aurait fait elle comme à
ses heures il s'empare improbable que ce
mec on n'arrive pas à le retrouver parce
que la bêtise d'un mec la bêtise d'un
mec elle salit tout le métier de mec qui
sait bien pour nous livrer le soares
commandes à deux euros cinquante les
consignes et mecque le green comme des
chinon et le même temps dans tu dois
pouvoir leur aucun lauréat si c'est de
pouvoir le retrouver il peut pas
aujourd'hui dire n'être débat tenir des
propos comme ça dans les cuisines
il ya de tout dans les restaurants
français il ya des ja d iliad et il ya
des blagues travail dedans il ya des
arabes qui travaille dans un restaurant
français ya des musulmans où il ya de
toutes les religions dans les rues dans
l'émeute dans les rayons ce même dans
les restos cacher il ya aussi des
musulmans qu'ils font là manger dans les
restaurants choisis a donc tout va bien
mais à deux tours et la bcn comme ça a
coûté 2 secondes ça sous verre ça
soulève justement notre problème c'est
que ce genre d'application le souci
c'est que c'est pas sécurisé c'est que
les autres
les livreurs se font usurper eux mêmes
ou donnent leurs comptes à leurs potes à
leurs cousins ça je voulais tous mais
parce que on allait au bout de cesser
toutes ces honorables de ta part mais en
fait je t'arrête vite fait parce qu'en
fait il ya un gros problème de fond dans
ce genre d'application quand tu prends
le humber et qu'il ya le photo du mec et
que c'est un autre mec qui vient de
chercher bah c'est aussi c'est un
problème de sécurité
donc on l'a malheureusement avec des
libéraux mais c'est aussi pour toutes
les autres applications comme ça il faut
sécuriser ces trucs
d'abord cela tombe très bien et je vais
dire bravo à des vidéos il y a le
porte-parole de délits verrou damiens
typhon qui vient de téléphoner à notre
production puisqu'on est en direct et
qui nous a dit qu'il se tenait à notre
disposition demain si on a des questions
des bravo à dérider voilà de réagir
aussi vite et donc et il sera avec nous
demande pour récupérer toutes les
questions et on fera on essaiera de
faire avec lui la lumière sur cette
affaire qui devrait avancer d'ici demain
bravo à des libéraux en tout cas d'avoir
réagi aussi vite bravo aux jeunes c'est
bien de réagir et c'est vraiment des
choses parce que c'est leur image qui
est sa chute vers sidi bel- réagir
en résumé je sais chérie les propos
racistes les propos homophobes les
propos islamophobes le les propos
antisémites franchement ça en ce moment
on doit le bannir absolument je vous lis
est chez nous ici voilà on le savait on
parle de tout et on essaie vraiment
d'être vraiment tous unis et n'oubliez
pas quand je le dis il ya des problèmes
beaucoup plus graves en ce moment que ça
et on a vraiment besoin d'unité
actuellement